[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ici l'europe en cette semaine
incroyable à tous points de vue où le
maître mot semble être vague seconde
vague de coronavirus à travers toute
l'europe vague d'attentats terroristes
en france et en autriche et résultats de
l'élection américaine tellement vague
justement pendant des jours que le monde
entier s'interroge sur la suite pas de
quoi apporter des certitudes de la
sérénité dans ce contexte nous avons
invité l'homme qui préside le forum sur
la paix à un événement international
portant sur des questions de gouvernance
mondiale de multilatéralisme qui se
tient chaque année à paris mais en
virtuel évidemment cette année entre le
11 et le 13 novembre en raison de la
pandémie pascal lamy bonjour bonjour
alors je rappelle que vous êtes aussi
l'ancien directeur de l'organisation
mondiale du commerce
vous l'avez été pendant huit ans et
ancien commissaire européen parce
qu'elle a mis des élections américaines
sous haute tension avec un dénouement
interminables à quel point cela
changerait quelque chose pour nous
européens
un président joe biden plutôt que donald
trump avec joe biden pour nous européens
il ya des choses qui changent
et puis il ya des choses qui ne changent
pas ce qui change c'est d'abord la
vision qu'il a de la relations
internationales trente et un démolisseur
géo bailon est quelqu'un qui négocie et
qui croit que le monde va mieux quand on
discute ensemble plutôt que d'échanger
des coups de poing donc ça ça va changer
la méthode va aussi changer la relation
europe etats unis a été hystériser
antagonisent et par donald trump comme
d'ailleurs le reste de ses relations
donald jeu belledonne est un homme
beaucoup plus mesurée beaucoup plus
pondéré donc la forme va changer ce qui
ne va pas changer
ces deux éléments très importants dans
votre la relation avec les états unis
d'abord c'est la rivalité entre les
états unis et la chine
elle est là pour durer pour les 20 ou 30
ans qui viennent
ceci a des conséquences importantes sur
le triangle etats unis chine europe et
nous devrons probablement avec byden ce
que nous n'avons pas réussi à faire
halte run coopérer davantage avec les
américains pour amener les chinois à
respecter un certain nombre de règles du
jeu de la coopération internationale et
notamment en matière commerciale
une bonne relation transatlantique
la réfection une relation
transatlantique et contribuera même si
même si pour des raisons géopolitiques
profonde et la crise du corridor à
accélérer cette évolution le monde est
en train de pivoter sur l'asie donc
trois ans de croissance en plus pour
l'asie en plein pour nous ça va
accélérer sa et ça ça ne changera pas le
regard américain celui de john dryden
sera inévitablement plus porté sur
l'asie et sur le pacifique que sur
l'europe et sur l'atlantique nous devons
donc nous rhdp à en tirer les
conséquences et prendre davantage de nos
responsabilités l'union européenne elle
a vécu pendant quatre ans de présidence
trump en se défiant de son ancien grand
frère américain qui a assuré en quelque
sorte le bon fonctionnement démocratique
le gendarme du monde est ce que cette
émancipation n'est pas finalement une
bonne chose à poursuivre je le crois
je pense que l'expérience trump nous a
en quelque sorte rendu plus adulte en
tant que union des européens dans le
monde contemporain et encore une fois de
toute façon de toute façon même avec joe
biden le regard américain sur l'europe
n'est plus ce qu'il était nous devons
donc nous mêmes en tirer un certain
nombre de conséquences et par ailleurs
nous savons que dans des domaines comme
le commerce
nous avons des intérêts différents
boeing et airbus se fritent depuis 20
ans ce n'est pas de joe biden qui va
changer cela
nous avons des problèmes à porter un
certain nombre de produits américains et
vice et versa ce n'est pas de job hayden
qui va changer ça il faut sans doute
revoir à la manière dont fonctionne
l'autel et l'articulation entre la
défense des états unis et la défense
européenne ce problème ne va pas
disparaître avec joe biden le président
trump il s'est retiré d'ores et déjà de
nombreux organes du multilatéralisme en
particulier des accords de paris sur le
climat est ce que c'est encore
réparables
vous avez raison trump pour des raisons
de principe parce qu'il veut casser un
multilatéralisme dont ils pensaient
qu'ils étaient mauvais pour les intérêts
des américains tram s'y retirer
l'organisation de la santé s'est retiré
de l'accord de parier et a par exemple
essayez aussi de neutraliser ou de
paralyser l'organisation mondiale du
commerce bon bailon reviendra sur ses
décisions
il reviendra à l'organisation mondiale
du commerce
de la santé il reviendra dans la camp de
paris ne nous méprenons pas c'est un
geste politique et symbolique
extrêmement important parce que ça veut
dire que les états unis rejoignent
l'ensemble des pays qui ont décidé de
lutter sérieusement contre le changement
climatique
ça ne changera pas le rapport de force
interne dans la politique américaine et
notamment et notamment si le président
démocrate ne contrôle pas le sénat
américain qui joue un très grand rôle
dans la politique étrangère
la vision de bayonne et pro transition
écologique la politique américaine
l'économie américaine le système
énergétique américain mettra beaucoup de
temps avant d'aller vers la neutralité
carbone qui est notre objectif à nous
européens pour 2050 c'est maintenant
l'objectif chinois pour 2060 il va
falloir que les américains bouge mais ça
prendra du temps
même si même si encore une fois joe
biden est beaucoup plus favorable à la
transition écologique que tron qui ont
font en y ait la nécessité à tout à fait
autre sujet mais préoccupant aussi des
attentats islamistes à paris-nice vienne
qui touche l'europe en son coeur comment
stopper enfin efficacement cette vague
je crois que il faut d'abord constater
que si l'europe est frappée plus que les
autres c'est que l'europe
à une philosophie en matière de
relations entre l'état le citoyen et la
religion et les professions où les fois
qu'il peut pratiquer nous avons nous
européens
un mode de relation entre l'état et la
religion qui s'appelle la laïcité
ceci nous met inévitablement en
difficulté face à des extrémistes qui
considère que la religion doit gouverner
toute la vie des gens l'europe défendra
elle a défendu dans le passé elle défend
aujourd'hui elle défendra dans l'avenir
ce principe de laïcité de neutralité de
la chose publique par rapport à la
religion
donc nous sommes plus exposés que les
autres pour des raisons de principes sur
lesquels je crois ou ne vont pas revenir
par contre ce qu'il faut sans doute
c'est dans ces circonstances qui nous
expose davantage mieux nous organiser
justement le président macron plaide
pour un renforcement des frontières
externes de l'union européenne est aussi
internes
ça n'est pas du tout le principe de
libre circulation dans schengen
si j'ai bien compris ce que je
présenterai pull france souhaite c'est
que la frontière européenne deviennent
moins poreuse qu'elle ne l'est
aujourd'hui
c'est une affaire de ressources c'est
une affaire d'organisation nous avons
nous européens contenu notre niveau de
vie les moyens de garder correctement
nos frontières extérieures canton
frontières intérieures il y a avec le
principe de libre circulation des biens
des services des capitaux qui est
fondamental dans l'organisation
économique de l'union européenne
il y à des exceptions de temps en temps
on peut remettre ce qui ad'ailleurs a
été fait par moments pendant
qu'ovide on peut remettre des frontières
le vrai problème c'est la gestion
l'administration des frontières
extérieures
il y a de ce point de vue là des efforts
à faire et je crois que la crise
actuelle le monde est ce qu'elle est
l'amie pencheront sur le rôle des
réseaux sociaux qui sont les supports de
tension exacerbée entre les citoyens
dans les élections américaines ou même
dans les attaques terroristes ils sont
pointés du doigt quel est le rôle
particulier sur les réseaux des
algorithmes les bulles de filtres accusé
de polariser les opinions comment ça
marche
et comment sortir de sa bulle petit
dessin d'animation signé céline schmitt
bull et ça fait du bien sûr fait au
hasard des réseaux sociaux et du web
nourrit le voyage intérieur
sauf que attention des algorithmes vous
enferme désormais dans votre bulle ainsi
si vous avez déjà cliqué sur une
publication d'opinion un homme politique
un mouvement
les google yahoo facebook twitter
instagram youtube et autres plateformes
auront tendance à vous re proposer du
contenu en accord avec vos idées vous
êtes piégés dans ce que l'on appelle une
bulle de filtres elle vous oriente en
priorité sur des propos et vidéos proche
de vos précédentes préférence
ces sites ne présente souvent qu'une
seule facette d'un fait or en france les
réseaux sociaux sont la source
d'information principale de 28 % des
citoyens et de la moitié des moins de 35
ans la hiérarchisation engendrés par les
bulles de filtres génère plus d'intérêt
chez vous internautes et donc plus de
rentabilité pour la plateforme mais du
coup elle ne vous met pas en contact
avec tes idées dissonante ne vous permet
pas d'exercer votre esprit critique ni
de supporter les points de vue divergent
vous n'avez pas l'occasion de vous
approprier les principes du débat
démocratique
ce qui aboutit à des sociétés plus
polarisé cloisonné crispé sur leurs
certitudes pour vous diversifiez sortir
de votre bulle
une solution consisterait à cliquer au
plus vite sur des sites que vous
désapprouvez histoire de rétablir les
équilibres du ying et du yang
ou alors plus ludique participer à notre
grand dialogue citoyen europe stoxx avec
notre algorithme à l'esprit de
contradiction
france 24 est une vingtaine de médias
européens vous met en relation avec un
citoyen qui a répondu de façon
diamétralement opposés aux sept
questions posées sur la gestion du
coronavirus l'économie les migrations
l'environnement on vous attend nombreux
sur notre site france24 points comme
cela chez versace ou intox
trois minutes chrono sont nécessaires
pour vous enregistrer et participer à
une rencontre en ligne riche y sentent
le 13 décembre prochain
top départ voilà pascal lamy quel rôle
justement des réseaux sociaux dans la
polarisation nos sociétés puis alors
qu'est-ce qu'elle rôle faut-il leur
faire jouer à l'avenir
oui très importants comme on vient de le
voir et je crois que le le diagnostic de
base est assez simple la diversité est
moins rentable que l'homogénéité dès
lors que les plateformes sont sous l'île
aux règles du jeu du capitalisme de
marché
la vérité c'est que dans le système de
capitalisme de marché dans lequel nous
vivons
si on laisse les marchés régulés
l'information et les réseaux sociaux
alors ils fabriqueront de l'homogénéité
parce que l'homogénéité c'est des gros
volumes et des gros volumes c'est des
grosses recettes
il faut donc sortir un certain nombre de
ces médias que sont les réseaux sociaux
de la loi du marché comme on l'a fait
d'ailleurs à certains moments pour la
presse comme on doit le faire dans
certains moments pour la culture les
marchés la manière dont fonctionne notre
système économique ne peut pas
s'appliquer à tous les plateformes sont
des industries qui traitent
l'information comme une marchandise et
plus y en a plus et rentable
plus on prend les mêmes et on vient de
le voir plus on fait de l'argent il ya
des limites
et donc il faut de la régulation
publique au niveau national au niveau
européen on retrouve les problèmes qu'on
a eus avec d'autres médias et notamment
avec la presse avec la radio éclaté à
certains moments qui est de savoir si
dans certains cas il ne faut pas réguler
le contenu ou l'organisation des médias
dans une société démocratique qui
inévitablement doit être plus diverses
la démocratie c'est la diversité à la
plateforme c'est le mot génialité ya
quelque chose qui ne va pas forum sur la
paix du 11 au 13 novembre à paris enfin
en virtuel en l'occurrence les chefs
d'état et de gouvernement seront
présents pour tenter de redonner une
impulsion positive au multilatéralisme
qui semble avoir vraiment du plomb dans
l aile avec une pandémie qui nous invite
à rentrer chez nous à nous
recroqueviller à nous confiner vous avez
raison
le multilatéralisme allait mal avant le
cog hill
il va encore plus mal avec le co vide
je pratique ces sujets coopération
internationale depuis une trentaine
d'années et je n'ai jamais vu un niveau
de coopération internationale aussi
médiocres aussi bas que cette fois ci et
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut
relancer le multilatéralisme
c'est le sujet principal de la troisième
édition du forum de paris sur la paix
nous allons parler non pas du monde
après que vite comme on l'espérait il ya
encore six bras quand on a commencé à
concevoir cet événement qui qui va
réunir à peu près dix mille participants
digitaux probablement trois ou quatre
cent mille follower sur les divers
réseaux sociaux dont on parlait donc
c'est un grand moment un grand rendez
vous international
hélas ce ne sera pas le monde d'après
qu'ovide c'est le monde d'avec peu vide
dont nous parlons il a besoin de
coopération
on le voit par exemple en matière de
vaccins et nous allons beaucoup parlé de
comment faire pour que ce monde dans six
mois dans mémoire ne se fracturent pas
en deux entre la partie qui sera couvert
par un vaccin et la partie qu'il sera
pas couverte comme un vaccin on va
parler d'environnement on va parler
aussi numérique cybersécurité chartes
internationales sur l'emploi et les
principes de l'intelligence artificielle
donc nous sommes en plein dans les
sujets d'aujourd'hui
et si cette crise que vides nous apprend
quelque chose c'est que nous avons
besoin de davantage de coopération
internationale plutôt que l' inverse
il faut associer à cette coopération
internationale d'autres acteurs que les
états classique que les diplomates et
qui ont souvent de grande qualité
fodé orange et faut des entreprises pour
des grandes institutions académiques il
faut des villes il faut
versifiée en quelque sorte les acteurs
de la vie internationale pour relancer
pour revamper pour ajuster ce système
international qui clairement est à la
peine et on le voit malheureusement dans
les dents des joueurs actuels merci à
vous d'avoir été notre invité
aujourd'hui pascal lamy vous restez tous
en notre compagnie nous allons
maintenant partir en direction du
parlement européen à bruxelles je vais
rejoindre ma camarade de public sénat
pour parler des abeilles on reste sur
l'environnement donc
[Musique]
bienvenue pour la seconde partie de ce
programme au coeur de bruxelles pour un
grand débat
vous aimez le miel et les abeilles
l'europe aussi ou en tout cas en théorie
elle a interdit en 2018 les pesticides
tueurs d'abeilles
j'ai nommé les néonicotinoïdes mais 14
pays sur 27
les utilisent toujours en effet à
bruxelles autorise des dérogations qui
ont du coup été très largement demandée
par les états c'est le cas de la france
jusque là bureau bon élève de la classe
européenne mais aussi de la pologne de
l'autriche de la belgique est ce bien
compatible avec le fameux pacte vert et
la nouvelle politique agricole commune
décidée depuis peu est censée diminuer
de moitié les pesticides d'ici 2030 dans
toute l'europe et pour en débattre 1 2
eurodéputés anna cavadini élue des verts
en allemagne un pays qui lui a
totalement un banni les néonicotinoïdes
dangereux pour la biodiversité vous
appartenez à la commission de la
protection des consommateurs bienvenue à
vous est alors avec nous côté français
jérémy deux serbes bonjour vous êtes
vous membre de la commission agriculture
ici au parlement européen et du parti
rignault c'est le parti des manuels
macron en fait en france qui a voté
comme un seul homme récemment la
réintroduction de ces fameux pesticides
contesté afin de porter secours plus
précisément à la filière des
betteraviers est ce que vous vous auriez
voté ce texte sans hésitation si vous
aviez été dans l'autre assemblée l'autre
hémicycle exactement mais si j'avais été
dans l'autre hémicycle à l'assemblée
nationale j'aurais voté sans hésitation
pour sauver la filière betteravière et
pour éviter de devenir notamment
dépendant de sucre d'autres pays
européens où d'autres continents voilà
la question était de
savoir si on voulait sauver les
betteraviers en français et la filière
je fais à des emplois derrière y'a pas
que les agriculteurs les producteurs de
betteraves
il y avait toute une filière derrière et
voilà donc oui j'aurais voté pour la
réintroduction anna camadini on voit un
de plus en plus un de dérogation
autriche pologne belgique est maintenant
à la france vous êtes cernés pour
l'instant aucune dérogation a été
accordée à l'allemagne a été demandée
mais plus il y aura de dérogation plus
la pression est grande pour le voisin
moi je vois vraiment dur j'ai à ce que
fit une pays et faire une exception
l'autre pays va faire une exception de
troisième pays va faire une exception et
je vais me demander pourquoi est ce que
on a une règle émotion à les nouvelles
européennes
c'est tous les états membres peuvent
décider à la fin de faire une dérogation
je crois que ça ne fait pas de sens est
ce que vous craignez du coup que
l'allemagne aussi lui demande sa
dérogation puisque les veaux autre
voisin la pratique fin prête d'utiliser
à nouveau les néonicotinoïdes oui je
vois les dangers parce que je crois
c'est aussi une question de compétition
parce que si de l'autre agriculture dans
les autres pays utilisent les néo
nicotine aux ide
oui ça va être mauvaise pour la
compétition avec les acteurs culture en
allemagne et je crois que c'est pour ça
on a des règles européennes
parce qu'on va avoir une compétition
juste en toute l'europe et aussi on veut
avoir une idée de protection pour les
consommateurs et aussi pour les abeilles
alors c'est vrai que la loi française
biodiversité aller plus loin que les
interdictions de l'union européenne 1,3
néonicotinoïdes là c'était 5
la france faisait en quelque sorte
figure de modèle pourquoi est-ce qu'on a
effectué ce grand retournement pour les
betteraviers alors que finalement on
aurait pu tout simplement leur verser
des subsides pour les récoltes perdues
c'était une autre méthodologie qui
coûtait peut-être un peu plus cher non
ça coûtait peut-être un peu plus cher et
est entre nous franchement est-ce que
allait finalement donné des subsides aux
agriculteurs juste parce qu'il ya de la
perte de récoltes
alors que ça allait impact et toute la
filière parce que il n'ya pas que les
agriculteurs derrière tout ça il ya
aussi toute une filière
donc je trouvais là on pollue et on se
déshabille devant vous avez dit la
france était bon élève et ben regardons
aussi ce qui s'est fait en france et en
europe
il y a il n'y a plus pour la betterave
qu'on a obligé de faire une dérogation
aujourd'hui en france c'est plutôt
satisfaisant enfin on a réussit presque
à hauteur de 80% à réduire notre
dépendance au niveau nicotine reid entre
autres bon bah ma foi c'est quand même
mieux et je pense pas sur notre
continent que l'alimentation est que
l'agriculture soit aussi polluante
qu'ailleurs alors je pense que les
agricultrices et les agriculteurs
européens ont fait un certain nombre de
changements sur les réputations
justement pour répondre aux attentes
sociétales et je trouve qu'on ne prend
pas assez souvent ça en compte
et aujourd'hui c'est justement une
dérogation pour sauver une filière
regarde quand même on si tout ce qui a
déjà été fait et regardons aussi ce
qu'on prend comme risque en tuant des
filières en tuant un agrégat dans les
chiffres les insectes de grands progrès
mais a quand même des problèmes en
l'espace de 27 ans on a perdu en moyenne
75 % de la biomasse d'insectes volants
scientifiquement si on a interdit c'est
entre on sait qu'ils étaient
responsables de la disparition des
abeilles
aujourd'hui les betteraviers qui veulent
des dérogations explique que
l'insecticide intervient avant la
floraison de la plante et donc est moins
dangereux pour les abeilles est ce que
vous les croyez
je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de
intérêt après l'industrie à confiture et
je comprends aussi que c'est quelquefois
c'est difficile pour les agricultures et
adapter au changement et à l'autre côté
je crois que les problèmes que vous avez
aussi des crises est c'est pire c'est
plus grave
on voit qu'elle atteint ménagères de la
biodiversité et les abeilles on sait
tous les enfants à savent qu'ils sont
nécessaires et ce serait pour notre
notre vie aussi pour l'agriculture y
danse
je crois qu'on a on doit vraiment avoir
un changement
l'union européenne a commencé mais je
crois que ça doit encore être plus
strictes et plus rapide
jérémy de salles sur cet argument
scientifique deux arguments par les
betteraviers qui disent qu'on donc
l'utilisation des néonicotinoïdes dans
ce cadre là ne nuit pas aux abeilles
vous vous y croyez vous avez évidemment
mais en fait j'ai pas lieu de croire ou
ne pas y croire c'est scientifiquement
prouvé que quand on traite sur une sur
une plante qui a pas fleury qui n'a pas
fleuri il ya de fait moins d'abeilles
donc du coup oui scientifiquement c'est
prouvé qu'il y aura moins de risque pour
les abeilles sur une plante qui est pas
en floraison que je pense qu'on n'est
pas allé au delà de des dérogations de
la commission européenne parce que elle
mentionnait bien un danger et une menace
compromettant la production végétale qui
ne peut être maîtrisé par d'autres
moyens raisonnables
alors est ce que est ce que c'était une
menace à cette échelle-là est
effectivement est ce que finalement on
n'est pas en train de voir des abus par
rapport à ces dérogations qui était
volontaire de certains pays et à gré ou
non par la commission d'ailleurs la
volonté de ceux qui se sont opposés à
cette réintroduction en france c'était
voilà de ne pas reconnaître
l'existence qui a été fait ce qui est
mieux bien sûr qu'il ya des choses
mauvaises et c'est pour ça qu'il ya eu
des des lois et des législations forte
pour justement diminuer arrêté stopper
interdire tel ou tel produit
mais par contre on n'a pas donc
forcément toujours pris le recul de
l'impact que ça pouvait avoir ce que on
peut dire on réintroduit pas la filière
betterave ton finit plus de betteraves
ya en france plus de betteraviers dans
d'autres pays européens six personnes
utilisent la dérogation est ce que les
françaises que les européens répond
arrêteront de manger du sucre demain non
nous irons chercher ou le sucre ailleurs
est l'un des neuf allergènes ou à lire
aussi le biais là eh ben oui on tombait
mais justement alors c'est sucre au miel
1 il ya deux camps justement le truc
c'est de savoir si si on essaye de
garder un équilibre ou pas jérémy de ça
vous parler du cas de la france mais il
ya d'autres dérogations ont été
accordées à d'autres pays
et là est ce que la commission elle
exerce suffisamment son pouvoir de
contrôler d'éventuelles sanctions parce
qu'il peut y avoir des abus et la
commission elle même a dit qu'il y en
avait eu je vois souvent qu'il ya
quelques problèmes dans les pays membres
que quelques pays membres ne réglemente
pas les règles européennes
il s'est surtout dans l'heure un dossier
de l'environnement
on voit ça souvent et notre groupe
les verts par exemple nous essayons de
donner beaucoup de pression sur la
commission de réellement être
investigués ces cas où les pays membres
n'a hammelmann par les règles
européennes et je crois que etc
spécialement dans le champ de pc site
important qu'est la commission
européenne contre eux mieux mais quel
est le pouvoir de contrôler très
concrètement de la commission qu'est ce
qu'elle peut faire et comment elle peut
le faire à la fin
le lin straumann plus forte c'est une
complète avec les traités sais pas
qu'est ce que c'est en français elle
peut mettre des sanctions sur les états
membres y ait quelque chose comme
sanction et je crois que ça c'est
seulement le dernier repas mais avant
peu la commission européenne peut avoir
un dialogue avec les pays avec le
gouvernement de vraiment implémenter ces
règles il ya aussi la question de vous
parliez du sucre mansle importe aussi de
pays tiers qui eux ne respectent pas du
tout la loi les mêmes règles sur les
pesticides et le brésil va nous dire
tout simplement et bien à bas dans ces
cas-là nous non plus on ne respecte pas
vous êtes en train de faire toutes
sortes de dérogation ça les incite pas à
des meilleures pratiques et à suivre le
modèle européen en allemand tout ça
enfin je crois que la question n'est pas
de savoir si on est pour ou contre la
réduction des pesticides on est tous
pour l'heure le colonialisme et que des
radiations mais non mais justement ne
fait pas que des dérogations c'est ça
qu'il faut aussi bien comprendre il ya
eu plein de réduction ces dernières
années parce que justement les shoots
les chiffres que vous avez donnée sont
alarmants sont critiques
donc il ya eu plein d'évolution plane
chose de faite les pratiques évoluent la
durabilité de l'alimentation et de
l'agriculture en europe est la meilleure
du monde
la cour des comptes européenne a déduit
qu'il y avait aucun impact sur la
biodiversité de tout ce qu'on avait
verdi soi-disant depuis depuis les sept
dernières années
belle l'alimentation et l'agriculture
reste européennes restent les plus sûrs
les plus durables et les plus contrôlées
du monde
alors effectivement on peut faire des
jets débat là dessus mais 16 autres est
bien mentionné des problèmes que je vois
une problème est qu on exporte en quoi
même quelques petits sites dans autre
pays qui sont interdits ici par exemple
au président
on exporte chaque été ses sites et les
prési l'utilisent 150
un principe que ça te dit ici et ça
c'est un problème et après on importe
les produits et c'est impossible
importer les produits où il ya quelques
récits du hockey que reste de la paix
ces sites sont donc encore dans les
produits et donc on à moi je pars le
premier pas ou le prochaine à et aussi
de
de réguler l'exploitation de pesticides
parce que je crois que c'est vraiment
horrifique ça c'est encore possible
il est grand les grands de la chimie
vont vendre vont vendre ailleurs depuis
que c'est interdit dans l'union
européenne
on pensait que les animaux et les
insectes notamment aller profiter du
confinement et la baisse d'activité liée
au corona virus on voit là que c'est pas
tout à fait le cas parce qu'ils sont
sacrifiés quand même sur dans le cadre
de cette filière sur le thème de la
biodiversité
écoutez moi je ne pense pas du tout que
l'on sacrifié justement les abeilles en
dérogeant juste que ronnie filière c'est
la filière betteravière qui encore une
fois les pratiques qui vont être
utilisés grâce à cette dérogation ne
viendront pas remettre en cause notre
volonté à maintenir des abeilles c'est
tout de la réalité des choses c'est
qu'il ya eu ces dernières années
encore une fois un paquet d'évolution un
paquet de changement les exploitations
et les agricultrices et les agriculteurs
dessus se sont organisés pour répondre à
la demande sociétale
il ya aucune agricultrice aucun
agriculteur qui n'aiment plus sa terre
que tous les citoyens et donc du coup il
faut aussi comprendre ça que dans la
nouvelle politique agricole commune la
commission veut une réduction de 50% des
intrants pesticides d'ici 2030
on n'a pas d'objectif clair ni de
sanctions suffisamment forte pour
imposer ça comment est-ce qu'on va
réussir et justement souvent on parle de
chiffres aux mains des pourcentages on
met des choses en place sans forcément
définir le moyen d'atteindre ses
objectifs
est ce que les agriculteurs ont les
capacités
les moyens les alternatives pour faire
face à ces demandes là n'ont pas
forcément répond ça pour les trouver
je crois que c'est pas seulement les
agriculteurs petits parce que ça
s'écoute comme ça mais c'est vraiment un
dustry énorme
moi j'ai lutter par exemple contre le
cliff usage dans les campagnes on
allemagne et c'était trop très grand
pour nous pour les verts que on veut
interdit le qui faisaient et sa pas
marché parce que l'industrie est
vraiment énorme c'est pas ce mot les les
petits taxis compteurs c'est vraiment
une image un peu faux je crois désolé
mais je crois que on doit on doit savoir
que l'industrie a culture et normes il
ya beaucoup d entreprises très grande
très riche et donc je crois que le
lobbying ici dans l'europe à bruxelles
est très fort et ça c'est aussi un
problème et à la cave a dit ni sur les
objectifs de la patte de la politique
agricole commune cette réduction de
moitié des pesticides à horizon 2030 est
ce que ça va dans le bon sens même s'il
n'ya pas d'objectifs contraignants
est-ce que ça va ça va dans le bon sens
ça va si loin et je crois que le pacte
vert est vraiment un progrès et ça va
absolument dans la dans le bon sens et
la voix de direction mais c'est que est
un peu déprimant pour moi et le vote sur
le cac le la politique de l'agriculture
comment la dernière semaine
parce que je crois que la cvo delà va
directement dans l'autre direction sur
la politique agricole
on a en effet dans les paiements directs
20% effectivement qui est dédié aux
femmes verdissement ou à aux échos
régime et ça vous considérez que c'est
pas assez pour remplir nos objectifs de
baisse d co2 est assez absolument pas
assez et je crois que c'est un peu
bizarre que la commission d'un côté dit
on n'allait pas clair et on doit faire
ça ça et ça c'est bien mais à l'autre
côté il ya le cnpac qui est absolument
le même pack qu'il ya vingt-deux années
et qui a pas changé à être devenus plus
verts enfin oui elle est souvent que la
pac pour vous aussi en amont du tout il
ya 30% en plus des paiements directs qui
vont être dédiés à l'environnement à des
nouvelles pratiques environnementales et
ces paiements seront basés sur de la
performance sûr du résultat
on avait une politique agricole commune
qui était plutôt en matière
d'environnement basé sur des objectifs
de moyens
là il ya 30% des zi he et quand ça c'est
pour le parlement est oui
c'est ce que le parlement a voté aussi
donc on n'est pas pour le coup on essaye
d'être le plus cohérent
donc ça c'est + 30 % donc tous ceux qui
disent il n'y a rien dans la politique
agricole commune de nouveau en matière
d'environnement
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire de plus qu'en
face et déjà c'est déjà conséquents et
et encore une fois il ya aucun secteur
d'activité à qui on demande autant de
changement et d'évolution en matière
d'écologie merci en langue et arnaud
rares et pour la trt trop pour l'autre
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis à très
bientôt sur nos deux antennes
[Musique]